okay i'm very excited today for the
chance to uh listen to and and
experience a joint from my man takashi
6-9 he is for my money
one of the most transcendent artists in
the history of western civilization
as a poet i put him on the level of
ralph waldo emerson
as a singer he's pavarotti as a
humanitarian his mother teresa
and to think he achieved all of that
despite suffering that horrific accident
where he fell into a giant tie-dye
machine
he actually well he actually looks a
little bit like a bowl of fruity pebbles
come to life
or maybe he looks like something out of
a skittles commercial in hell
but i say all of that in a positive way
it's all part of his genius really
now the song we're going to be
experiencing today is a classic
it's an oldie one of the takashi 69
songs that my dad was listening to back
in the day
uh it's not from takashi's newest album
which by the way is available for now
for purchase it's called tattletail
uh tattletail being a little reference
to the fact that he's a gang member who
sold out his crew to avoid 40 years in
prison
um lots of people think that you know he
lost street cred for that
because he's a snitch and all that but
personally i think it makes him
more relatable because i can tell you i
would totally flip on my crew to avoid
40 years in prison
wouldn't anyone if i'm going down i'm
taking the whole level
if i had a crew i mean at all i would
flip on them that's probably why i don't
have one
and i'm never going to get one if i keep
talking like this but if i had a crew
i would dime them out in a second i
would sit down for the interrogation
the detective would come in and 12
seconds later i will have told them
everything
i got your back for life
she did it
[Music]
it would be that easy i don't think i've
ever had a friendship that i wouldn't
ruin to avoid a lifetime in prison
but in any case that's just the
background on the artist now let's get
to the song this one is um
from way back in 2017 like i said it's
an oldie
uh but but certainly a goodie it's
called cuda
um all right let's uh let's give it a
listen
[Applause]
but they never pop up i got the drop boy
everybody watch out
on my own
see can i just say here you know i
appreciate this dichotomy um
and already we're seeing the nuances of
takashi 69 he's got the puppy he's being
affectionate
in the next moment though he's pointing
a gun at your face it's as if to say
yes i can be sensitive i can appreciate
these more pleasant moments i can stop
to smell the roses but i can also shoot
you in the head for no reason
now a therapist might say that that's a
symptom of a psychopathic personality
disorder
but i say no this is just what it means
to be human really we can all relate to
it
on some level let's uh keep listening
and she was stupid stupid i really do
this if i taught
[Music]
okay now let's take a second to reflect
on these lyrics
i roll up i'm gonna be booted stupid
and shoot it stupid brought a knife i
brought a ruger stupid
i really do this if i towed it then you
know i shoot it
and i'ma prove it back back don't be
moving stupid or imma use it
now this is the kind of moment in a
takashi song where i know
that he gets me you know he understands
where i'm coming from
and i feel a little bit less alone in
the universe because so often i walk
through life
feeling frankly booted and often my wife
will say to me honey you're not
booted are you and then i say yeah i am
booted
i am and she'll say we've talked about
this and i'll say
okay well if you if you don't want me to
be booted then get this sucker up out of
my face
in that case so just a normal marital
spat that couples have while walking
through bed bath and beyond on a on a
tuesday
um let's get back to the song
really don't need all but then i leave
get back kick back back up
okay i do have to say uh just just just
one note here
probably you don't want to take a job as
a cameraman
on a takashi 69 music video because
you're going to have a lot of people
pointing probably loaded guns right at
you i mean
there are a lot of basic gun safety
protocols that are being disregarded
here
if you don't know how to handle one of
these things you got no business
carrying one
so that is a concern you know i just
wonder how many cameramen perished
during the making of this video
everybody's dancing jumping up and down
drinking god knows what probably high
and they're literally singing about
killing people and meanwhile they all
have loaded guns and they're pointing it
at the camera that you're holding i just
it seems like a hazardous combination of
factors
i hope they have workman's comp is all
that's really all i'm saying
but you know what however many cameramen
died
they didn't die in vain they died for
the sake of true art
let's continue
n words running out they mouth but they
never pop out
i got the drop on your spot everybody
watch out all my n words on 50.
so you know he hopped out mobbed out ops
out
we gonna show what we about i think what
takashi is saying here
is what he's saying is is is that is
that is that
man is a creature which reaches beyond
himself which cries out for something
greater than himself
running out their mouth right meaning
the words as you are deep in prayer
spring forth from your mouth running
streaming
but words are just abstractions just
symbols takashi is saying
you as a person on the other hand you
are bound by physical laws you are
attached to your mortal
coil and you cannot pop out you cannot
hop out
uh you cannot overcome that limitation i
got that drop on your spot takashi
observes
and it's it's so true because we are all
as it were dropped onto our spots we are
all plucked out of eternity
dropped into this physical frame and we
can but obey its limitations but the
kashi 69 is really asking us
to reflect on this fundamental tension
between man's desire
and man's limitation honestly when i
listen to a takashi six nine song and
when i look at him i'm reminded you know
a lot of of uh
of c s lewis the mid 20th century
christian apologist very similar in many
ways
and something c.s lewis once said was if
i find in myself a desire which nothing
in this world can satisfy
the only logical explanation is that i
was made for another world
and i imagine takashi 6 9 had that
passage in mind when you wrote those
lyrics because
very similar themes are at work here
let's uh let's keep listening
okay listen to this again you can talk
hot on the internet boy
that's that goofy we ain't into that boy
black van pull up to your mama crib boy
tire up drive that [ __ ] off a bridge
little boy
that's um oh okay that's just him
threatening to kidnap your mother and
drive her off a bridge i think that's
all that is there
so that's that's that's that was the
point of that line
i guess um let's just let's just keep
let's keep going oh my god it's really
gangbang took that dance
rap about it do the same thing we're
gonna pull up something
we don't do the race
okay let's uh let's collect ourselves
here and
and and focus in on that final line of
the song
he says we post up we don't do the race
you go and die today stunning
it takes my breath away just this line
alone is
poetic and biting and rebellious and and
satirical
what he's saying here is that we post up
like fence posts you know we erect
fence posts walling ourselves in hiding
from the reality of our own mortality
we don't want to enter into the race of
human existence because we know
where that race ends and indeed that it
ends
to enter the race is to approach every
moment near the finish line but the
kashi says
you go and die today he says today maybe
not today literally but but one day
on a day someday you will die so he says
embrace
the finitude confront your life in its
brevity
and live it with fervor and honesty
paint your hair in rainbow colors and
your teeth
and get together with your homies and
dance dance
takashi 6 9 a scriptural scholar in his
own right he's pulling you can tell
directly from the book of isaiah which
says and behold joy and gladness slaying
oxen killing sheep eating flesh and
drinking wine
let us eat and drink for tomorrow we
shall die
that's exactly the truth so live now for
tomorrow you shall die
or in fact today you might die
especially if you're high on crack and
dancing with a loaded gun
and i think that's the lesson we really
take away from this
something for us all to think about as
we go about
the rest of our day which may be our
final day
thanks for watching everybody hey if you
like this show then uh then put your
money where your mouth is and actually
subscribe and give us the thumbs up if
you don't it will hurt my feelings so
please do it now